[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اول طفله اقتنت لعبه باربي تكاد
تكون في السبعين من عمرها الطفل اصبحت جده
وباربي ما زالت الشابه الابديه هي اكثر من
دميه هي اشهر فتاه في العالم او اجمله
النار ربما ابقوا معي
[موسيقى]
سته عقود من عالم باربي في معرض تفاعليا
ضخم في هوليود ثلاثه طوابق
1800 متر مربع من المرحله الورديه
والذكريات الحيه لعشاق تلك التي كان
الشقراء في الاساس على عكس معظم شقراوات
حاليا
[موسيقى]
ساعتان تكفيان للعوده الى كل مهن وهوايه
باربي العمر ليس مهما فالجول هنا تؤكد بان
الدميه اصبحت من رموز النوستالجيا كانت
حلمه صغيره بجمل وصارت ايضا حلم الكبيره
بالجمال
يمكنك في هذا المكان تسجيل غنائك وعزف
الموسيقى في الاستوديو ثم هناك اذاعه
باربي حيث تقدم الاخبار والنشرات الجويه
على التلفزيون وبكل تاكيد هذا هو مكان
المفضل في هذا المعرض واليوم ضيفتي
السومه
[موسيقى]
في هذا المكان نشاهد باربي الطبيبه
والرحاله ورائده الفضاء فمع مهني باربي
تطورت رساله مهمه للاطفال ان بامكانك ان
تكون من تشاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات